while some sensational developments from
the phone hacking trial here
at the Central Criminal Court at the Old
Bailey we've just been told that partial
verdicts in this case have been
delivered Rebecca brutes the former
chief executive of News International
has been found not guilty of phone
hacking Andy Coulson the former editor
of the news of the world has been found
guilty of phone hacking in Stuart Kutner
the former managing editor of the news
of the world has been found not guilty
of phone hacking that is count one that
conspiracy to fight to hack phones count
two and count three that relates to
misconduct in public office these are
charges facing Clive Goodman the former
royal editor of the news of the world
and also Andy Coulson the former news
editor of the news of the world those
charges the jury thus far have been
unable to reach a verdict so we
understand that they will be going off
to deliberate again on those counts
counts two and three moving on to count
four this is a charge again of
misconduct in public office a charge
against Rebecca Brooks that she had paid
for a royal photograph of Prince William
and a bikini when he was at Santos she
has already been acquitted off that
charge so she is not facing a jury's
deliberation on that particular count
moving on to count five this is another
misconduct in public office this relates
to Rebecca Brooks and her so Rebecca
Brooks alone this is the payment of an
MOT official four stories relating to
military matters again Rebecca Brooks
found not guilty of that misconduct in
public office on count five on count six
this is a conspiracy to pervert the
course of justice Rebecca Brooks was
standing charged alongside her personal
assistant Cheryl Carter
and that related to the removal of seven
boxes continuing notebooks and other
items that may be of interest to police
investigating phone hacking removed in
the days before Rebecca Brooks's arrest
from the offices News International
again the jury has come back and found
out Rebecca Brooks and Cheryl Carter are
not guilty of that can of that
conspiracy to pervert the course of
justice the final charge count seven
this is three defendants who faced our
charge Rebecca Brooks her husband
Charlie Brooks and Mark Hanna who was
the head of security at News
International again this was a
conservative the course of Justice that
related to the removal of computers and
other electronic devices once again the
jury returning verdicts on that not
guilty for Rebecca Brooks not guilty for
her husband Charlie Brooks and not
guilty for Mark Hanna
so those partial verdicts in we've still
got counts two and counts three for the
jury to go back and start deliberating
over but already at this stage with a
good portion of these verdicts in
a sensational developments as far as
Rebecca Brooks is concerned as she has
been found not guilty of all the charges
that she faced here at the Old Bailey
Andy Coulson the former editor off the
news of the world and then former
communications director at number 10
Downing Street has been found guilty of
a central charge that he faced that's
conspiracy to intercept voicemail
messages otherwise known as phone
hacking